[Music]
today's question comes from dennis in
washington my friend and i started a
paint contracting business this year
we've already earned 1.4 million dollars
with 500 thousand as net profit
we're worried about tax season because
we've never experienced financial
success like this before our accountant
recently told us we need to make some
expensive business purchases as
write-offs and my partner wants to buy a
truck for cash i really don't want to
spend thousands of dollars for potential
small tax savings what is the real wise
thing to do fire your accountant
right now as an idiot
i'm serious accountants that can't do
math should not be employed
this is this just pisses me off they're
saying spend a bunch of money to save a
little bit of money well let me explain
to you how this works okay if you go buy
a truck
you do not get to write the truck off
and save the cost of the truck in taxes
let's say you have a
50 000 tax bill so you go buy a 50 000
truck
it does not work that way honey
you're accounting some [ __ ] all right
so what happens when you buy a 50 000
truck is you get to depreciate that
truck over three or five years depending
on what type of schedule you put it on
and as you'd appreciate it let's just
say we put it over five years so the
maths easy on my 50 000 that's 10 000 a
year oh by the way you don't get ten
thousand dollars off your taxes either
you get ten thousand dollars off of your
taxable income and so if you're in a
thirty percent bracket it saves you
three thousand dollars this year
to buy a 50 000 truck your accountant is
a [ __ ]
that math doesn't add up
you don't need to be trade 50 000 for 3
000 you're a [ __ ] okay that's just
straight up that's just an idiot now
here's the thing if you go buy business
equipment that you actually use in the
business or
most of it is going to be on a
depreciation schedule of some kind under
some cases you can write the whole thing
off in one year maybe it will
depending on what biden has done with
the trump tax stuff you may be able to
write it all off in one year but it's
even then ten thousand dollar write-off
for a ten thousand dollar expense saves
you three thousand dollars on your taxes
no you don't need to go spend money
to save on taxes
you're just gonna pay some taxes honey
you became very successful i'm sorry it
sounds like they should have just been
putting that money aside knowing i'm
guessing they haven't been doing
quarterly estimates yeah this is their
accountant as a [ __ ] this all happened
to this year so that this is all new to
them but you know taxes aren't new
they've paid taxes since they've been
working so yeah uh they've got to find a
new tax if your partner wants to go buy
a truck for cash you should do that with
the money that he takes out of the
business as his share
of the profits
and get ready to pay taxes on it
do not buy things for your business to
save on taxes only buy things for your
business that causes your business to
become more prosperous
now if you have some legitimate things
you can invest in that cause you make
even more money in business let's always
invest in those but we didn't do that
for tax reasons we did that because
we're going to make more money on the
item we purchased than the item cost
that's called a return on investment and
that's what you do in business you don't
put money in anything else but there is
no situation in tax where if you spend a
dollar you save a dollar
no if you spend a dollar you save maybe
a quarter
maybe three cents
possible exception would be if you spend
some money on a new accountant who can
do math
and that might be a good return write
that off that's the question have i been
unclear about accountants who can't do
math any of you cpas and accountants who
tell people to go run up their expenses
in a business in order to save on taxes
ought to have your butt kicked up around
your neck
it's ridiculous
when you people running businesses start
doing stuff just for taxes you about to
be out of business when the lawyers and
the bean counters run your business you
are screwed
you have to make decisions that are
business decisions
i'm guessing these are the same people
that buy things on their credit card on
their business card to get the rewards
it's the same mentality of i'm gonna
spend 10 grand to get
200 my favorite one was my friend who's
an electrician the irony of this just
can never has been able to escape me
his idiot accountant told him that it
was okay for him to buy a houseboat
and write it off as a business expense
now there's no irony here that we're
talking about a boat with electricity
right electrician with a houseboat but
but i'm trying to explain to him junior
it's not a business expense that's not
his name his name's not junior
but um i'm like good lord bubba i mean
you understand he said well i'm going to
have like business parties on it i will
i will entertain customers how many days
a year two days a year okay you can you
can actually depreciate
to
365th
of this houseboat
and you can write off the booze that you
bought for the party and that's it bubba
that's it your accountant is a [ __ ] oh
my god this is so freaking stupid yeah
the fraction on that hurts my brain it's
so little it's yeah yeah and it's just
and and it's an electrician buying a
boat with water and electricity on it
that just that is always it's just
bothering me but yeah
uh yeah but the yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh this is something we get with entre
leadership all the time business people
who are smarter than their accountants
smarter than their lawyers start taking
orders
from people that are dumber than them
people smarter than you around no no you
no no go go to ramseysolutions.com click
on elp for taxes get you a new tax
person that can add
can y'all tell can you tell it bothers
me a little bit a little riled up there
dave i'm not gonna lie bothers me a
little bit but i like the fire today
it's um
well business stuff especially riles you
up you've been in this business long
enough 30 years and i've been helping
small businesses with entre leadership
we've been tens of thousands of them for
decades and i just love small business
people and this young guy man they went
out and they kicked butt
they are absolutely killing it man i
mean they're wearing it out a million
dollars in that revenue in the first
year half a million
contracting that's a lot of pain profit
and what happens to a wonderful young
guy like this
yeah
yeah just out of control man it's
absolutely out of control you just can't
live that way
so um no i um
you you make
all
business decisions on economic values
not on tax law
whatever tax law happens happens now you
can do a few things here or there on
taxes you may want to
push some expenses into december too
late now
if you're on a cash basis accounting
system so that you can get the write off
in last year
uh looks like biden's going to change
capital gains so would have been a good
idea to dump some capital gains stuff
last year you can do some tax planning
around some things
and you should do that you should be
wise about this but this idea that we're
going to run up expenses in business to
save on taxes
exhausting you done riled them up dennis
you done riled them up this is the
ramsey show